day after day this week the wait for the
report into partygate went on but
there's little sense of great
expectation amongst the people we spoke
to in the lincolnshire constituency of
great grimsby i don't think anybody on
grimsby fish market is particularly
interested in the subray report or even
understand who she is 55 60 65 70. most
seem more interested in the price of
fish than downing street parties the
catch of the day here is icelandic cod
and haddock not the details of a report
which could bring down a prime minister
whether somebody has a party or not
doesn't actually affect my economy or my
business uh so yeah bad form but i'm not
i'm not convinced that any other person
would have done anything differently
traders say a visit by boris johnson on
the 2019 election trail won people round
grimsby was part of the so-called red
wall of labour seats which collapsed
neighboring cleethorpes is more of a
bellwether constituency it also voted
conservative
but will the message sent by bring your
own bottles of booze gatherings cost the
conservatives at the polls
these commercial divers think partygate
might not mean the end for the downing
street boss
so do you know anyone that feels really
angry towards boris johnson no no no no
not at all no i do like him i'm not
supposed to like him i'm from the mine
in mining village um
i do like him i don't want him to leave
i i hope he does stay in power
so you actually don't think that
conservatives winning the red wall seats
that this is going to do for him
i do i think it will alter
a few people i think there's a lot of
people
will not vote for him again because of
everything that's happened
i don't think he's fit
to be prime minister he should be able
to count off what he's done but let's
move on
at this sewing club there is anger but
they just want the party hangover to end
with boris
a lot of the time
he's acted more like a complete buffoon
all the things
which i disagree with completely and
utterly yeah and and i don't disagree
with what you're saying
but
it just seems like a witch hunt at the
moment every day
is boris this
boris has done this everybody's
fed up
and it doesn't matter what party you're
in or anything
everybody is fed up because people want
to get on with their lives
so for now the wait for white smoke from
sue gray continues lisa holland sky news
lincolnshire